le coût de la vie augmente pour faire
ses courses son plein d'essence ou
simplement s'équiper pour la rentrée
scolaire et les tourangeaux ne sont pas
au bout de leurs surprises car la taxe
foncière va elle aussi montée en flèche
la municipalité de tours se défend de
devoir gérer son budget et notamment les
nombreux investissements en cours mais
aussi de se mettre à léquilibre par
rapport aux autres villes de france deux
cent mille habitants sébastien branger
depuis 2015 la ville de tours n'a pas
connu d'augmentation de sa taxe foncière
en début d'année la nouvelle
municipalité a voté le relèvement de
cette taxe à 11 6% seulement depuis
l'inflation est passée par là et les
tailles a ajouté 3 4 % de plus sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
c'est ainsi que tour avec près de 15% se
retrouve deuxième derrière marseille qui
culmine à près de 18% une deuxième place
sur le podium dont les 40 % de
propriétaires tourangeaux se serait bien
passé qu effectivement en tant que
représentant de l'un certain nombre de
propriétaires bailleurs je peux vous
confirmer que la nouvelle n'est pas
accueillie dans le plus grand
enthousiasme 15% d'augmentation taxe
foncière sur un bien qui est bien
souvent un petit investissement
complément et en perspective d'une
retraite c'est pas nécessairement une
bonne nouvelle et ça vient s'additionner
à toul et les autres dépenses qui va
falloir réaliser pour rénover
énergétiquement et bien pour la mairie
cette augmentation était nécessaire au
regard du sous investissement chronique
de la ville dans ses infrastructures
depuis 30 ans elle s'est ainsi engagé
dans un plan de financement sur dix ans
afin entre autres de rénover écoles
équipements sportifs et culturels
la volonté de maîtriser la dette et de
lancer les investissements et donc on a
décidé d'activer le levier fiscal pour
pouvoir financer ce plan pluriannuel
d'investissement donc la taxe foncière
elle a pour objectif unique et premier
d'apporter plus de services publics à
tous les usagers de tous les bâtiments
de la ville de tours depuis la
disparition de la taxe d'habitation et
de la taxe professionnelle les mairies
n'ont plus que ce levier fiscal la taxe
foncière a déjà augmenté en moyenne en
france de 28% en dix ans